[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to the br
gridiron punishment league here's how
it's going to break down we are going to
pick a team week by week daily fantasy
style and of course we all want to win
but the real trick will be making sure
you do not lose so you don't have a
crazy punishment i am jack settlemen and
i will be winning every single week hi
everybody i'm amanda and i'm going to
win this league
what's good everybody i'm female raps
i'm just here to compete bro i'm gonna
try not to take too many l's so i gotta
do too many of these challenges and end
up looking crazy so lou young here all i
do is win t-pain said it best but i'm
gonna do it the best
fortunately the team sent us our own
boxes which will also have our
initiation punishments inside of it this
is fragile these things are crazy all
right let's open them up
[Music]
please accept this invitation to the
gridiron punishment league you'll find
yourself at the mercy of whatever the
bleacher report app audience deems
appropriate for retribution for the
league's weekly fantasy football losers
this invitation will serve to present
your first punishment and closed you
will find the world's hottest chip
sincerely it's report gridiron out the
gate this is gonna have people run to
the bathroom go get whatever you need to
be prepared for this i would go get milk
if i were you a few moments later i
gotta make sure i gotta make sure this
milk good though
you're not gonna care if the milk was
from 1984 once you eat this [ __ ]
if you guys are ready the pocky one chip
challenge i will see everyone on the
other side good luck
oh my god oh it's getting hot my
esophagus is burning
i don't like this i'm surprisingly still
breathing
my ears hurt
oh my god when you use the milk it comes
back stronger don't drink the milk i'm
telling you
oh my god lou is dying
it's worse when you breathe out flemo's
on his phone he's picking his team for
the week he's not even bothered i think
all them gears in louisiana do me some
good i'm feeling like conor mcgregor
right now i don't fault it i don't beat
it i think we're in a better place
mentally than physically all right
hey man
everybody get it come on clap it up for
yourself hey
now we all have our own chip on our
shoulder the grim reaper chip fans will
be able to pick our punishments put us
in more tears more embarrassing
situations to the loser of the br
gridiron league the nfl is here and we
are ready to do it